i mean like i think we talked about this
like two weeks ago where you have to
evolve with the times right
and there's got that you have to have do
you have to find a way to
garner interest in your sport it's like
keep up or get left behind yeah i mean
you know
sports like boxing and chess are lucky
that they've been
they've had such a good history and a
good legacy where that has like kind of
carried them a bit in the modern age
yeah where they had like a solid fan
base yeah but obviously you know
if they want to modernize to a point
where they want to get bring in a bunch
of new viewers you got to mix it up
and chasse is having like a massive
renaissance now yeah yeah yeah i'm happy
for chess
like chess streamers the biggest ones
are yeah hey cara is pulling in like
plus 25k i think a stream
uh like and a bunch of the other bigger
ones pulling in like over 5k
viewers on not like you twitch just
because you're like pulling new viewers
i feel like
that doesn't like dilute you know the
history that has already been built
like people are still going to look back
to like the greats of the times yeah
once they get into all the greats going
on right now it's just people just
people just don't like that they're not
the ones that are solely being talked
about right
i mean i i think one of one of the big
things is that i think
i don't know i might be talking out my
ass but it seems like
like a lot of the younger generations
are less there's less of a focus
on sports and more people are like
getting into like video games and stuff
like that like we literally talked about
how uh my nephew got bullied because he
wanted to play sports but everyone was
playing fortnite whereas when i was
growing up
yeah it was the other way around the
cool kids were playing sport and that's
why sports
had such like so many eyes in it and now
i think because
less kids might be interested in sports
you know
you have to find a new way to appeal to
a younger audience otherwise
they're just not going to give a [ __ ] at
the end of the day this is going to
sound weird
but i think that video games are now
more accessible than sports yeah yeah
and i think that's
why they're doing better like if you
want to play a game of rugby or football
you need what like at least five aside
you need a lot of people to get that
done you've got to give up and a lot of
space because you have a lot of space
right like anyone can play a video game
on their smartphone or whatever anyone
anyone can download chat you know i can
play madden
yeah like it's like you know a lot of
the sports like i love
i love swimming but like finding a
swimming pool in japan is so hard
yeah without paying out the ass right
yeah and there's not one anywhere near
us and like i don't i don't [ __ ] know
where to go
like i mean there's one there's like
gyms that have them but you have to pay
like
150 bucks a month to access them yeah
most sports that i
liked as a kid i realized how lucky i
was that there was like in the uk you
have so many
sports centers all around where you can
do this but now i'm like fine it's
so hard to do the sports that i want to
do and get into it yeah i want to get
back into sports
and get like a newer generation into
them because it's like i mean i'm not
being funny how are you going to
convince a kid to go
you know play golf when he can play
mario golf
it's so accessible so easy like
and the problem is golf looks so boring
yeah i'm
sorry but golf like i i cannot there are
some sports where i'm just like i do not
understand how people can watch this and
be entertained because
i've like i've played golf before um
because like i
um i used to like live kind of near a
driving range
and it's just so i you know had a period
where i just really enjoyed playing golf
it was really satisfying to like smack
the ball
um i wasn't rich enough to afford my own
golf club so
you know how another barrier to entry
yeah yeah it's like that's not a barrier
to entry but
it's really fun to play golf my god it's
so boring to watch
i cannot watch a golf game i mean i'm
sure the people who watching this who
love watching golf and i'm sorry to
disappoint
but there's like there's so many sports
like that though like i used to play
tennis
like a lot i can but i cannot sit down
and watch a tennis match oh i don't know
i can
some sometimes some games but they're
all long they all lost yeah they are
they are but
it's so but i find it just so weird and
interesting how like
i can i myself love playing the sport
and yet i can't bear to sit down and
watch the sport
yeah like you'd think if someone played
the sport they would be
just as interested to watch it as well
right because they're not always because
it's like
the inverse is also true as well where i
might like have no interest in playing
the sport but i love watching it
oh yeah but like that's good yeah like
me
is that a sport but uh yeah i mean like
for example i don't know there's there's
always going to be like massive sports
like football
oh yeah uh wait that's not gonna go away
that's like too deeply ingrained but
i feel like that that's why the olympics
is so weird to me right
because you end up watching a load of
these sports which
you would in any other circumstances
have no interest in watching but
yeah it's the olympics you know does
anyone want to watch like men's
volleyball
anyone you know i never gave a [ __ ]
about archery until i watched it
there are a lot of sports that are
interesting when you have them
or you experience them once every four
years oh yeah
they're and your country's kind of in
the race right because you've got a
little you've got
you've got a horse to root for right
yeah you know
i don't think uh archery week by week
monday night archery you know
like you know you've got your old story
lines you've got to build up yeah
the olympics definitely opened my eyes
to like some sports being
really fun i never [ __ ] saw him oh my
god curling and curling i
[ __ ] love watching curling's fun i
never thought i'd be into it but i was
like
you know what this this is hype as [ __ ]
i don't know why
curling is like a mario party game that
actually got turned into a real
it's like a mini game but like every
round is curling
literally like facts and they're like
let's just [ __ ] make it real yeah
that's one sport i really want to play
like try out